hi guys in this video we're going to
talk about how to raise something called
dopamine dopamine is what's called a
motivational molecule because it
actually improves your motivation your
get-up-and-go your ability to jump out
of bed so when you're deficient in it
you can't get out of bed you lose your
focus you lose your cognitive function
become depressed at anxiety apathetic
feet and hands get cold decrease libido
mental sluggishness carb cravings other
than that you're perfectly fine so
there's certain unhealthy things that
will trigger dopamine as well like crack
cocaine for example little baby right
here it's called cocaine right when a
person gets hooked and addicted to crack
what's happening is that this drug is
triggering this neurotransmitter which
is elevating the your mood and different
cognitive functions temporarily
gibble me and then what happens is the
more you do it the more you lose the
effect the more that you want to do it
so you're in this really terrible cycle
because it needs more and more cocaine
to stimulate the same amount of dopamine
so you become very very addicted and of
course what it's doing all the time it's
giving you this artificial sensation
which then gives you the need for more
and more of it so it's it's a bad habit
now the other thing is if you consume
caffeine for example or any type of
stimulants what you're doing is you're
triggering dopamine over and over and
over again and then you'll every time
you do it over time you lose that effect
so you need more and more coffee
more and more stimulants to create the
same effect just like any drug so let's
talk about what dopamine is it's a
neurotransmitter okay neural
transmitters are similar to hormones in
that their communication particles yet
the neurotransmitters communicate to the
nervous system where about hormones
communicate through the blood okay that
would be the difference okay so there
are things that you can do to stimulate
the production of dopamine like taking
l-tyrosine as an amino acid which is a
precursor because maybe you need more
raw material or improving the stomach
acids so you can break down the proteins
to formulate this neurotransmitter those
are some things and by the way the way
that you would know that you wouldn't
have enough stomach acid is if you would
have gas indigestion or bloating
okay then you'd want to add outside of
vinegar something like maybe something
like patanè hydrochloride just to
increase the acidity so you can make
more of this neurotransmitter on a
flipside you also have reducing stress
too much stress in cortisol will nullify
the production of dopamine okay and this
is actually really really important so
you would want to maybe take some B one
from nutritional yeast but let's say for
example you have a history of being a
drug addict and you're like you're in a
really bad state right now and you want
to spike it up there's a type of B one
called cell Butte to mean
so yes it's synthetic but it's stronger
and if you use it on a temporary basis
it'll actually be okay
but just make sure that you take it in a
blend of nutritional yeast so therefore
you're not depleting any of the other
factors any time you take excessive
amounts of a certain isolated synthetic
vitamin you can deplete the other
vitamins that normally come and that
complex and this goes for vitamin C
vitamin B vitamin E across the boards
rhodiola is another herb to help
decrease stress holy basil is another
one that's really good to lower stress
as well and the next thing is to reduce
sugars okay because what that does is it
sets up a situation that you get insulin
resistance insulin resistance is a
situation when you can't absorb these
amino acids to make the
neurotransmitters so you would have to
fix this insulin resistance to be able
to have this work and everything else is
not going to work unless you fix that
point because it's kind of like the the
door that allows everything to go in
there to kick it in and make it work
correctly and there's something else you
can take to actually improve dopamine
levels and it's something called uridine
okay it's a natural chemical that is in
nutritional yeast but it's really good
for cognitive issues helping to
stimulate more dopamine but if I were
you I would take a nutritional yeast by
itself that way you can actually get
this right here
and the b1 and actually improve that
situation okay lastly get more Sun more
Sun will improve the dopamine levels as
well alright thanks for watching hey if
you haven't already subscribed press the
button below and I will keep you in the
know hey that runs